the government has been clear
that protecting consumers is our primary
focus
and shapes
our entire approach to this issue
we will protect continue to protect
consumers with the energy price cap yeah
yeah the global gas situation mr speaker
has had an impact on some
uh energy suppliers
and i have been in touch daily with off
gem and as they set out yesterday there
are more than 50 suppliers in the
domestic market
and we may unfortunately see
more suppliers exit the market in the
coming weeks
but it is not unusual for energy
suppliers to leave the market for
various reasons particularly
when wholesale global prices
are rising ofgem and government have
clear well-rehearsed processes in place
to make sure that all customers
are supplied with energy
our approach will be informed by the
following principles protecting
customers especially vulnerable ones
from price spikes
and the solution to this crisis will be
found
from the industry and the market as is
already happening and governments i
repeat will not be bailing out failed
energy companies lastly we would like to
see a competitive energy market which
can deliver choice and lower prices the
energy cap the energy price gap which
continues to protect millions of
customers will remain in place
and very finally consumers mr speaker
come first
and this has always been
the center piece of our approach